depuis une semaine vous avez
certainement déjà reçu plusieurs
messages proposant toutes sortes de
réduction les ventes privées sont
partout une semaine avant le début des
soldes
beaucoup comptent bien en profiter j'ai
fait un achat mon cadeau de noël que
j'avais pas eu
j'ai eu en promotion voilà on vient voir
si jamais il ya quelques petites bonnes
affaires à faire enfin de fait ce qu'on
fait encore noël ce week-end nous donc
on peut très des petites choses il ya
moins de monde
après il y aura la foulée puis en
général on n'a pas toujours ce qu'on
veut et détail disparaissent très vite
du côté des commerçants certains
espèrent rattraper leur retard
car la mobilisation des gilet jaune a
entraîné une perte de leur chiffre
d'affaires
pour d'autres ces ventes privées font
surtout partie d'une stratégie
commerciale
on va pas dire que c'est pour récupérer
du chiffre qu'on n'a pas fait en
décembre parce que ce chiffre là on ne
récupérera pas donc c'est plutôt pour
essayer de récupérer même des nouvelles
clientes
voilà ça va permettre de fluidifier le
trafic d'avoir des clients répartis
sommes plus aux périodes est justement
de m'en avoir cet impact plus violents
de jeu du jour des sables on va dire
après les ventes privées
les soldes d'hiver débuteront mercredi
prochain jusqu'au 18 février